benjamin castaldi je vous jure c'est pas
une race est regardée alors benjamin
castaldi conduit aux urgences après un
plongeon maladroit alors il n'a pas fait
ce plh la saison de tout ça non pas du
tout benjamin castaldi victime d'un
accident pendant ses vacances en corse
benjamin castaldi transporté aux
urgences après l'accident de bonjour moi
j'ai lu ça et j'étais inquiet mais
j'étais pas bien aimé j'étais chartrons
algérie ce qui s'est passé en fait il y
avait un bon ton et au bout du ponton il
y avait de l'envié mais la mère élabore
et moi je pensais que la mer était
profonde
bien sûr vous d'importance et profond
normalement bien sûr qu'il ya un panneau
ne pas plonger
vous n'êtes pas prêt pour thalassa bon
en tout cas en tous les cas le fait est
que je suis arrivé au bout du ponton
j'ai plongé j'ai plongé et il n'y avait
pas assez de fond et j'ai tapé la tête
fin tj ce qu'on appelle un choc
médullaire ouais je sais qu'en fait j'ai
été vraiment situation de dents de
paralysie totale des bras et des jambes
pendant une minute
j'étais en train de me noyer et c'est le
fils d'un ami à moi qui a compris que
j'étais vraiment en train de nuit qui
m'a sauvée de la noyade
ma femme est évidemment très inquiète on
avait les pompiers conduit aux urgences
pâte à koufa bref et je peux vous dire
que depuis cet excédent je vois plus la
vie pareille ça mais c'est vrai mais
vraiment alors vous le voyez comment
l'allumage d'avoir aux et les yeux vous
[Applaudissements]
gsk glaxo est ouverte voix n'ont même
pas alors je vois la vie en rose c'est
vrai nom c'est vrai mais ouattara que
vous avez vous avez et steam même
paralysé pendant quelques années gt gt
en saison 2 va de paralysie totale des
bras et des jambes pendant une minute
il parie toujours vous n'arrivez pas à
il paraît que voilà regarder je lui met
une bouteille regardez il va arriver
alors c'est quelque part c'est se
laisser le bras gauche c'est le bras
gauche le bon maintenant le mauvais
temps les deux sont mauvais et regarder
devant la bouche ils n'arrivent pas à
ceux ci réalisée sans trucage
c'est vous c'est une première mondiale
on nettoie des règles ne faites pas ça
chez vous non mais sans rigoler c'est un
truc de ouf enfin doc gynéco bonnes
vannes moi je sais pas encore qui n'est
là bas mais voilà bah ça va revenir
non là c'est fou quand les stocks arrive
pas je peux pas ah ouais samatar
histoire oui bah ça ça serait mort
par contre pas fait et si je te mets une
bouteille de whisky non plus et j'aime
pas supposer que j'ai découvert
tu penses que lui est arrivé et m'a il
va arriver à le lever alors on a
d'ailleurs une photo d une radio de vous
regarder de castaldi regardez voilà
voilà
alors pour le basset s'est pas
complètement fou parce que la jambe
gauche depuis les dernières elle est
totalement excusez moi vous êtes un
petit village et là c'est vrai j'ai
l'orteil ya donc alors et donc si je
peux vous de la lancer ou arrêter les
bagages alors vraiment alors les
baguettes et là c'est surtout à vous
arrêter de me taper arrêté de me
chercher et rester tranquille et rester
comme ça vous êtes très beau voilà je ne
vous trahirai pas cette année c'est sûr
et certain
même si vous me cherchez je me défendrai
peyrelade même s'il votera oui oui
j'aimerais défendre et jamais été
vraiment un connard
excuse moi qu'est ce que c'est que ce
look de ringard sans rigoler oh non mais
ça incroyable et regardez on a aussi une
vidéo
parce que quand vous avez eu l'accident
oui je suis allé voir vos excès on a la
vidéo on à leur action regarde mais
beaucoup les ont démenties
sachez qu elle ne pleure pas pour
l'accident le pire jusqu'à 30 une
pension alimentaire que ça bien entendu
et elles sont dégoûtés